[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hi George
and Ken how are you today we're having a
blast what's up all right guys um so
George a special thank you first off for
you know reaching out to me
[Music]
um wait George is calling callers now
what is happening feels like we have he
sent me a DM yesterday with this
question I said hey I want to dig into
this will you call the show this is a
perfect call for Canon I to take I want
to hear Ken's thoughts so we we got him
scheduled and I'm so elated that he was
able to call you really are a man of the
people you are a man of the people
exactly happened right there all right
Stephen what's going
on all right guys so um as I mentioned
to George um I'm a former uh lottery
winner um ion a million dollars a
million
dollars yeah a million dollars on a
scratch ticket um W in the state of
Virginia when I was 28 and I'm
36 nice now and I have gone through it
all um o down to zero yeah so I am a
part of that statistic that uh I don't
know 80 or 90% of lottery winners lose
it um I swore that I wouldn't be but
here I am and uh what was your take home
what was the takh home after the yeah
766 th000 was what the actual ticket was
worth it wasn't actually worth a million
dollars I know that's what they
advertised right and then I paid tax is
on that so take home was
555 okay and over the span of eight
years you drain that 555 in your bank
account to zero yes sir can you for the
benefit of the listeners and a dark
curiosity can you tell us where that
money
went yeah so I mean obviously I bought
the ticket so I gambled to buy the
ticket right um so that that never
stopped um was more so with casinos uh
Sports gambling Etc um
quite embarrassed by it
um you know absolutely well this is
clearly there's a addictive behavior
here have you dealt with that over the
last eight years are you still grappling
with
that yes um I've reached out to Gamblers
Anonymous um I actually have an
appointment set up uh to speak with
someone uh to hopefully get get me over
the addiction and and move forward is
this the first step you taken as we're
talking now what's that is that the
first step you've taken to get control
of
this yes and I realized that it was an
issue um but you know still would still
would go at it wow so would you say it
was largely gambling did you buy you
know a house a car upgrade your
lifestyle definitely upgraded the
lifestyle I a little bit I did buy a new
car um I paid cash for it uh when I won
um I paid off my debts um except for one
I had two student loans um I did not pay
off the federal student loan I paid off
the private student loan um and that's
the that's the debt that I carry today I
don't I don't have a car Deb okay well
we're going to help you take the right
Next Step we're not here to beat you up
um we know you're you've been dealing
with this Addiction on top of now kind
of being at rock bottom so lay it out
for us are you working right now and
what's your income
yes sir um I'm in restaurant management
my income is 75,000 good and how much
debt do you have
left um 29,000 all right how much money
do you have in the bank if
any uh about
6,000 okay that's good news and are you
single I have a girlfriend um not
married but have a girlfriend and we do
live together okay and the 29,000 is
that one student loan or a bunch of
student loans what kind of debt is that
it's two different uh federal student
loans that total the 29,000 okay so we
can start to chip away at that with some
of the savings you have your ,000
emergency fund now we're going to debt
snowball these pretty quickly making 75
knocking out 29 how quickly could you do
that well I I have roughly 2400 a month
left over after all bill paid um so you
know divide that into the roughly 30
grand so what 15 months 16 months yeah
you'll be done with this in under a year
I mean 2400 month that's 29 Grand in a
year so let's focus on knocking this out
over the next 12 months then we're going
to get a fully funded emergency fund so
that you never have to go back into debt
again so you have Financial Foundation
but the bigger piece is getting our
spending under control and getting this
addiction under
control yeah yeah I I don't really spend
all that much I I don't live a high
fluent lifestyle I just I gamble you
know and that's that's where it's have
you have you cut off the the ability to
gamble whether it's your friend group
whether it's the cards whatever it is
that's enabling you to do this have you
cut those pieces
off I don't really know how to cut I
have a couple of friends that that are
well aware of what's going on
um and you know we've spoken in detail
and are they the kind of people that
will challenge you hold you accountable
check in on you will you be honest with
them could you listen to
them absolutely yeah they they have done
that um we haven't spoken recently we
had a conversation about six months ago
um about all of it um I I haven't
stopped since then um do you have any
credit cards open no sir okay what do
you what are you gambling on right now
is it football or what what is it yeah
I'll do sports sports gambling um is
that through an app or
website no it's just live okay because
the one thing you can do is delete all
the apps delete all your logins all your
payment info for all these sites you can
block these sites too through your
browser yeah I think we need to put
someware steps in place I think George
is Right Stephen I I think you have to
do that but you have to have some
accountability like your girlfriend like
it would be like Gamblers Anonymous will
help with that for sure it will but but
I think you need to decide today I I I'm
not again in any way Tak it away from
therapy or anything else but I I I do
think you need some accountability and I
would almost treat your gambling like I
would a teenage you're looking at stuff
they shouldn't look at on a phone and I
would get the girlfriend involved or a
really close friend and set it up to
where they set up where there's
notifications or something there's got
to be a way to do this but at the end of
the day you're going to have to just
decide can I wean myself off of this can
I watch can I go through one weekend one
weekend at a time can I just go through
a weekend and not
gamble yeah and I've you know I've
always been um I've always held myself
accountable in all areas of life um
except this one you makes up yeah accept
this also here's the deal it's
frustrating I know it's frustrating and
I and again I think you need help and I
I would absolutely go and get with a
therapist I would I I'd make that uh I'd
make a couple phone calls today I think
you need to take action on this and also
some accountability and you know what
else I think you ought to put that
competitive fire into making some more
money I'm going to challenge you
professionally what are two or three
rungs up the professional ladder for you
uh give yourself a challenge to go make
more money by growing professionally
thanks for the call appreciate your
honesty Stephen we're going to walk with
you on this this is the ramsy show
create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life